I hear that like only hot people
if you think it's Yanni I wish to
disconnect with you yeah yeah Lee yeah
so people have been freaking out about
this yeah knee versus Laurel debate
there is no way that this could be Yanni
this is not saying Laurel this is only
saying a knee it just says Laurel a
bunch of times it just sits a Nana's but
I only hear yeah knee and we're seeing
this story everywhere the New York Times
wrote this thing up even musician Yanni
commented on this some people have
really been enjoying this debate while
others are completely over it including
myself so I want to figure out once and
for all is it Yanni is it Laurel and how
is this phenomenon even happening so if
to get more of a backstory on this I
decided that I'm just gonna reach out to
the source and contact the original
redditor that posted the audio clip so I
reached out to this guy named Roland and
the action was pretty quick to respond
he said that he came across the words on
a website when he was working on a
project a long time ago I remember my
sister saying why do you keep playing
Yanni and then my sister's friend who
was doing homework with my sister said
that definitely says Laurel I was very
confused after that I don't remember the
name of the website unfortunately after
doing a little bit of digging I was able
to find the website he actually found
this audio clip on a vocabulary calm
which is incredible because it solves
the problem of what word is being said
we can definitely say the word is Laurel
but we can't argue that it sounds like
Yanni sound is how we perceive things
and now I want to figure out why that is
so to get to the bottom of this I think
I need to help with an expert there are
a few theories that I had heard that I'd
love to hear your thoughts on ik one
said
the age of your of your ears will change
how you hear it is that yours are any
truth to that there's some truth let's I
doubt that it explains this the
information we're talking about is
nowhere near that frequency range you
would have to have more significant
hearing loss for that to be a major
factor
well another theory that I had heard was
this says more about the speakers you're
listening to the audio from then your
ears or your perception it's about both
really because you know you can do the
experiment and use the same exact
speakers and the same audio system and
with a bunch of friends
some of them will hear Yanni reali
others will hear Laurel if you were to
play with the frequency and move it up
or down you would think those the
differences would become more
transparent to the audience is that true
I think if you lower the frequency of
the original stimulus it's more likely
to turn into Yanni and then if we moved
it up we would then see or hear the
Laurel actually to be Laurel would be my
guess
yes so I decided to put this theory to
the test
I put the audio through one of my
editing programs and started playing
with the pitch one now I was already
hearing Laurel but as I started going
lower and lower and pitch him I started
to hear Yanni clearer and clearer but
maybe you were already hearing an e so
when you go the opposite direction I'm
sure you'll agree long you start hearing
Laurel so now what does this mean I
usually stop talking about it
[Music]
[Music]